violin shrine is a rather terrible place
when you think about it sure the fire
keeper will always be there for you
but what about when you're not there for
her she's disposable
forgotten just like champion gundyr
who's stranded in another dimension
or like the handmaiden chained to this
fate
for what must feel like an eternity
remember well
i am undead bound
forever by the shrine's curse
as the fire is linked over and over
kingdoms change
and so too does the shrine in this world
as we know
the shrine is a literal graveyard of ash
quite befitting
of an exhausted world though one
constant
through it all is the suffering of the
fire keepers
these women aren't as selfless as you
might think
no they're prisoners just like you and
they fight for the linking of the fire
for with the linking of the fire comes
rest
finally the curse of the undead will be
lifted
and i can die human long have i awaited
one such as you
one who can set me free ashen one
link the fire for the lords of cinder
for the ashen prisoners for all those
held to preserve the fire
link the first flame though as we've
come to learn
this rest is temporary and the curse
never was lifted and yet the legend
of the linking of the fire continues to
infect the minds of many
undead are shepherded towards the first
flame and the kingdoms of the gods are
always designed
to enable their sacrifice in some way
have you ever noticed that the
incinerating kiln is never too far from
the kingdom of men
filing shrine is a crumbled peak of new
londo
the throne of want sits below drangleic
castle
and in lothric hidden behind the king's
garden
along a trail of ash and untended graves
is the current iteration of firelink
shrine and
what must be the thousandth fire keeper
capable of sending us forward
to be face to face with cinder itself
surrender your fires to the true
air let him grant death
to the old gods of lordran
deliverers of the first flame those that
failed to become cinder
are cremated all the same their ashes
scattered in the untended graves by the
soul of cinder
those that succeed become lords of
cinder
but it says a lot about the future that
they fight for
if our lords have refused to fight for
it a second time
and so the grand betrayal was conceived
this betrayal of the flame was not a
novel concept
by any means but perhaps it was still a
necessary one
considering it led to the link of fire
being threatened
and at the bell tolling for the
unkindled
according to his cinders the prince
lothric was destined to be a lord of
cinder
and was cherished by the royal family
though
ironically he was born ill shriveled and
frail
unable even to wield the platinum sword
that was his birthright
conversely lothric's older brother
lorian was a great champion of the realm
while his younger brother's sword would
never be wielded
his was scorched black by the flame of
the demon prince which he had slain
single-handedly
the great tragedy that's referenced so
often in their law
is surely that while prince lothric was
chosen to be a lord of cinder
prince lorian was the one suited for it
and so lorian must have had a great love
for his brother
for he embraced lothric's curse merging
their two souls
tragically this left lorien mute and
crippled yet
it is said that lorian indeed wished it
so all the same
there's this great mention of the grief
of the twin princes
for once they came together they
rejected everything that had made this
sacrifice necessary
so instead of linking the flame they
settled in their throne room
and simply watched the fire fade from a
distance
and with their strength combined fought
off any who would seek their cinders
ill-starred are they who take the throne
i shall not stand among them the fire
linking curse
the legacy of lords let it all fade into
nothing
mark my words
ash one you
remain
among the accused
if we were to join them in their rest
this is the fate that the princes would
have us live
a darkened shrine most likely their
shrine
is hidden behind the chambers of the
consumed king
and items tell us that if a place is
devoid of light
so too will it be devoid of time perhaps
this explains away the terrible
convolution
within this place justifying how those
in the future shrine
can be pulled to this realm like the
swordmaster
justifying how we physically walk here
from present day lothric and accounting
for the dead fire keeper who
is from the past and tucked away
but of all the things here from past
present or future
she is the most consequential for she
is the one that's holding the eyes that
enable a fire keeper
to betray the flame ah found her did we
and the black eyes that shimmer within i
see
just as if it were but yesterday
we did all we could to spare her from
them
much has happened since mayhap
i should reprise thee of what the thin
light of these eyes
might reveal to the eyeless fire keeper
scene of betray things never
intended for her ken visions
of this ages end
the eyes are said to have belonged to
the first fire keeper
and of all the would-be lords of cinder
it makes the most sense for prince
lothric
to have had access to such an heirloom
he is
after all the descendant of old royalty
inheritor of the throne
and it seems that he and lorien coaxed
their fire keeper
to stifle the flame back in their age
much like we can
with the eyes in our possession now ask
yourself
how does ludleth know about any of this
ludleth refers to the eyes
and the woman they're planted upon in
the past tense
it follows that somehow he linked the
flame
after the princes refused to look not
in bewilderment as i say
i linked the fire long ago becoming the
lord of cinder
if substantiation be thy want
set thine eyes upon my child cause
this sad cadaver there's something wrong
in this dialogue listen to how guilty
and how defensive he sounds
a true lord of cinder would have no need
to constantly reaffirm his or her
legitimacy
and we get closer to the truth on this
by listening to him as he sleeps
as he dreams about the nightmarish rite
of linking the fire it cinches
to the bone it hurts
please help me be done with me
no god no i cannot bear it
it burns burns help me
i am a lord
[Music]
are we flame be like
but i shoulder the world
forgive me i am not to blame
i'm not from his half-burnt corpse to
the guilt that we hear
it seems most likely that ludleth
partially linked the flame
perhaps it's because of him that there's
a light in this world at all
that the bell was able to toll for help
truly though
this story is one that i can't possibly
claim to have all the answers to
for example was it possible for weak
little ludleth to link the fire
because the twin princes had already
defeated the soul of cinder
if ludleth could link it why couldn't
champion gundir
who was the first fire keeper why are
there black knights here and
why is this place still so dangerous to
our unkindled
perhaps this place was laid with
defenders for a reason
for of all the shrines this one seems
the most geared towards stopping anyone
who would dare rise
and somehow link the fire it's difficult
and
perhaps pointless to come through here
champion gundir did arrive
only to find the coiled sword of the
shrine broken
in advance and the fire keeper gone
grave wardens patrol the graves
are devoted to hemorrhaging any
reanimating corpses
and the only fire keeper that patrols
the grounds
is a scholar the daughter of crystal
is drawn to any embers that would walk
through this shrine
and of all the things that don't make
sense in this story
it does make a lot of sense that there
would be a scholar here
for the first of the scholars as you may
recall is said to have doubted the
linking of the fire
and was also a private mentor to the
royal prince
at the highest peaks of lothric castle
are the grand archives
home to the scholars they're the faction
with a close relationship to the
previous king osiris
who went mad studying their store of
knowledge
and this close relationship between the
crown and the scholars has clearly
carried over to the new
young prince lothric but who was the
first scholar
there are many candidates but many have
theorized that it was oldia
and while all the evidence behind it
being aldia is circumstantial
the rise of the unkindled is certainly
something aldia would have fought for
a destiny beyond the scope of light
beyond the reach of dark
a painted world inhabited by ash a
future
born of this world but free of its
curses
in no small way the princes are
responsible for the rise of ash
an unintended consequence of their grand
betrayal
think you can kill me in pvp well this
is your chance
in exactly two weeks on the 23rd of
september
at 7 pm pdt i'll be hosting a pvp event
at the kiln of the first flame arena if
you invade me
and if you defeat me our first five
winners will each receive a gorgeous
limited edition copy of dark souls the
vinyl trilogy
which will be officially released later
this year our next 10 winners
will receive a physical copy of dark
souls beyond the grave by third editions
which is this comprehensive well-written
exploration of the entire game
lore and all here are the instructions
this event will take place on pc
ps4 and xbox one and while i'll
personally be fighting on pc
you're still eligible to win prizes if
you defeat one of my
champions that i'm going to send to
fight on my behalf
on xbox one and ps4 so to compete you
just have to
get everything you need to enter the
arena so acquire the champion's bones
from ariandel
burn them at firelink bonfire and then
join the undead match
just like i'm doing on screen select
duel
at the kiln of the first flame with the
password discord
or lowercase and my name during the
fight won't be vatividia
you won't know that you fought me unless
you defeat me
and i message you afterwards on discord
and to be eligible for these prizes you
have to be a part of our discord server
because that's how i'm going to message
you click the link below and join
and once you're there change your
discord nickname to the name of the
character that you'll be fighting with
in the arena
this will just allow me to message you
in the unlikely event that you beat me
so again this two-hour long event takes
place in exactly two weeks on the 23rd
of september
at 7 pm pdt you just need to join the
arena you need to join my discord
you have to have the same name as the
character you're fighting with on
discord so i can track you down
and yeah so in the description there's
everything i've said here
there's the discord server link there's
the rules and there's a link to
both of the rewards if you just want to
buy them outright
there's a countdown timer below there's
a time zone manager
everything you need and i'll also have a
video out in exactly two weeks on the
day that this event takes place
just to remind you one more time so i'll
see you then